- Please welcome Joe Manganiello!
(audience applauds)
Hello!
- [Joe] Hi Drew.
Big fan, big fan.
- Right back at you, for a long time,
and there's so many things I
wanted to discuss with you.
I guess I could start off
with the beautiful romantic
aspect of your life.
You and Sofia just celebrated
your fifth wedding anniversary.
(audience applauds)
- [Joe] Thank you, yeah.
- That's romantic.
And I was reading about how you said
that you initially first knew
that you could really trust each other
and knew to put each other's priorities
and that you just kind
of had this, like, system
of how you started out and
you would stick with it.
- I knew because there was
almost like a "Gift of the Magi"
type of situation,
where unbeknownst to me,
she had put what I wanted in life
and out of a relationship
or a commitment first
and unbeknownst to her I had
done the same thing for her,
so there was this one day in particular
where we both surprised each other
by making some difficult
decisions for each other
on behalf of the other person,
and in that moment, I knew
that I could trust her.
I knew that she cared about me
and I cared about her,
obviously, and that was it.
And I went ring shopping.
I was actually shooting
"Magic Mike Two" at the time,
so the guys on set were like,
you know, giving me advice,
you know, about ring shopping
and things like that,
so it was fun.
Those guys actually had a hand in it,
in me actually putting the ring on her,
getting the ring around her finger.
- [Drew] Every woman's fantasy!
Not only, you know, Joe Manganiello,
but just the cast of
"Magic Mike," you know,
backing it all up.
Jesse Tyler Ferguson
helped set you guys up,
which is also a total fantasy,
'cause all women hope that someone's going
to step in and do a setup.
There are many movies made
about this whole setup thing
and it doesn't happen in real life.
- Well, there actually were two friends
that were instrumental.
One was Jesse, yes. Unbeknownst to her.
And on my side, I was very
good friends with Jess Cagle,
who at the time was the editor-in-chief
of "People Magazine."
Jess actually let me know via
email before anybody else knew
that she was single so that
I would have the advantage.
I needed that advantage
because she was shooting in New Orleans,
so I flew straight there.
Jess Cagle said, "She's
single, get down there, go."
- [Drew] And you did.
I feel like there might need
to be a movie or a novel
made into; it sounds like
a Hollywood dream fantasy.
And we don't know that it really happens.
And to hear that it does is so inspiring
because all women are like,
"If only, like, a guy ever
would, like, book a plane
ticket, show up, anything."
Wow, good for you. And thank
you on behalf of women.
- Hey, you know, I guess
I'm old-fashioned and yeah,
I believe in all of
those stories, you know,
whether it's "Romeo and
Juliet," whatever it is,
you know, I think for
me, my job was to chase
and I think somebody, whoever
that is, one or the other,
accepts one of the roles and
the other takes the other role,
and you have the opposite
magnets are the ones
that come together, not the same.
So, I mean, we're getting,
like, philosophical here,
but I think that that is the case,
and I think what gets
confusing is when people
come at each other with the same polarity,
I think then that can
sometimes deaden out.
Somebody has got to chase and
somebody has gotta be chasing.
- [Drew] I love it.
Polarity is one of my very favorite words
in the English language because it just
immediately describes
the dynamic of, you know,
it's the perfect antidote
to perfection, I agree.
I don't know if you'll
believe this about me, Joe,
but I am a lot of energy,
so I don't know what my magnet
would be on the other side.
There probably some
corpse over in the corner
who doesn't have much to offer,
that's probably who I
would be magnetized to.
- Well, if you have a lot of energy,
somebody has got to come in with more,
and that's the thing.
(Drew laughs)
If you want that woman who's
successful and outgoing
and funny and smart, like,
you gotta come in over the top
and that's, you know, that's a commitment.
You gotta meet that. You
gotta meet that energy.
- I just want to quickly
recommend that you do a Ted talk
on how men should conduct
themselves in the world.
I understand that actually, was it Sofia,
do I have this correctly?
That brought a little
someone, if you will,
into your relationship?
- Yes. So, you know, Sofia wanted a dog.
And she, one day, got sent
the picture of this cute,
like the cutest dog you've
ever seen in your life
in this shelter, "Dogs Without Borders."
And there was a Saturday morning,
she said, "Come meet the dog."
And I went, "Oh, I forgot. Okay."
So I walk out and this
cute little thing perks up
as soon as I walk outside,
jumps off of the lap of
the person from the shelter
and came running over to me.
I said to them, "Okay, you
know, let me, I'll try her out.
You can leave her with us for a week."
So once the shelter people left,
we found out she was sick and
she had a cyst on her belly.
- Am I right about this?
Like you knew that something
wasn't right with her
and you took her to a vet?
- Yeah, so the next day
I took her to the vet
and they said, "Well, we're going to try
to change your diet.
We think there might be
some stones involved.
This cyst might be a cancerous tumor.
We don't know, but we're
going to run some tests."
And I said, "I don't
want to run any tests.
Like, here's my credit
card, whatever it costs.
You put her into surgery,
you take those stones out.
Look at her; she's in pain."
I kind of felt like the
universe had handed me
this little thing that needed help.
And probably the reason
why she was at the shelter
in the first place, this
cute, sweet little dog,
was because the previous
owners, I'm guessing,
looked at the, you know,
the fees for surgery
and thought, "Well, you
know, we can't do that,"
and surrendered her.
So she was in this spot where
she was going to be put down
because no families were taking her.
She was going to see families
and no one was adopting her.
And so I just thought, you
know what, no matter what,
I'm going to help this little thing out.
She's been with us ever
since, she loves me,
and she's just been like, you know,
the light of our lives
since, since we've had her.
- [Drew] Oh my goodness.
- Yeah, there she is.
- There she is. Oh no, she's so cute.
Look at that little sausage!
Oh my goodness, okay.
(upbeat theme music)